good evening everybody and welcome my
name is shannon rose mcauliffe and i'm
the manager of the student arts programs
here at mit
i'm also joined by my colleague stacey
debartolo do you want to give a quick
intro
sure my name is stacy de bartolo and i
do
finance and operations for the arts at
mit and i'm also the manager of the
student art association
so both stacy and i work with a lot of
these really fantastic and engaged
members of the mit
arts programs stacy and i will be
co-hosting this event this evening i'll
have to be leaving a little bit early
because i'm
also hosting another event so stacy and
i'll be
tossing the talking stick back and forth
but in the meantime
before we get underway i'd like to
remind everybody here
that this event is being recorded and it
may be made publicly available
on the arts on the radar website or
elsewhere in the future
so if you don't wish to appear in the
recording please make sure that your
video
and your audio are muted during the
event and you can always feel free to
contact us
at artsontheradar mit.edu if you have
any questions or concerns about this
so moving right along thank you all so
much for being here this evening we're
really excited to hear from this
quite estimable panel of students and
recent alums who have been deeply
involved in the arts at mit
these students are some of the most
active and engaged members of this
hustling and bustling arts community
their interests span music dance visual
arts journalism
sort of anything you can think of so um
this evening we've got ethan navadomski
moderating our panel ethan's a junior
and he's majoring in
comparative media studies and computer
science and engineering
he's also an arts scholar and with that
i'm going to turn things over to ethan
to get things rolling
so hi everyone it's nice to see you all
uh
and so we're gonna be going through and
obviously
uh thanks for joining us uh we're gonna
start today
the evening with julia uh each member is
gonna get five minutes and at the end
we'll have a q
a so feel free if you have something
that comes to you can probably drop it
in the chat but just remember there'll
be time for questions
so no need to interrupt while people are
presenting uh with that let's go to
julia what do you have for us
cool well hi everyone i'm julia
chatterjee
i'm a junior studying mechanical
engineering or course two
i'm currently in the process of moving
into this windowless room in cambridge
um with my old floor mates from my dorm
so
that's been fun um but i guess a little
bit about me and arts at mit
before i got to mit i would say i was
super involved with the arts
uh fashion was always something that
really interested me but i like
deemed it a frivolous i don't know hobby
i guess
and i definitely thought there would be
zero conversation about it at a place
like mit
and i was definitely wrong about that um
but anyways i was really lucky that i
found myself in the freshman arts
seminar
ran by stacy because i learned about so
many arts opportunities at mit that i
had no idea existed
to name a few uh the lending the slap
which is they're not doing it this year
but you get to take home pieces of art
and i've done it for the past two years
uh the ceramics studio the glassblowing
studio i got access to
arts classes over iep for free that
everyone else had to pay like 100 bucks
for
so that was super cool and also through
that seminar i learned about um
fashion opportunities that i got
involved when got involved with my
freshman year and have been involved
with ever since
so one is the trashion show which is an
annual fashion show
put on by the undergraduate association
on sustainability
and it features um garments made of
upcycled materials from designers all
over the boston community
and uh if you look up mit trash and show
on youtube there's a video
featuring me but also really cool
designs um that you should definitely
check out
and last winter i guess i
also i was the project lead for it so i
got to reach out to a lot of cool
designers
um and it was super cool to see dress
made of wires and trash bags and i feel
like the events
gained popularity in the past years i
believe it will have some virtual form
this winter as well so be on the lookout
for that
but the other thing i got really
involved in was the infinite magazine
which is mit's fashion and design
publication
and when i first joined my freshman year
i really had no idea what i was doing
um i didn't have much graphic design
experience but i just always knew that
the magazine was something that like
i wanted to be a part of and every
semester i just felt like i needed to
contribute
um so since my freshman year i've like
knit a bra for that magazine and made
earrings out of
fruit and now i'm the editor-in-chief
for this issue so i'm super excited
about
that we're making another virtual issue
and i did want to
share my screen to show what i made this
past
issue six
um
cool so what i ended up doing is
i initially when we were like still on
campus in january like
i just knew i wanted to make pants um
but i didn't know why
and then when i got home i f like
because of quarantine
and mit closing i found all these really
cool fabrics in my closet
and decided that as a reaction to this
one size fits all like everyone leave
and everybody
put on a mask um situation that we were
just thrown into i made
one size fits all pants and i had
everyone i was quarantining with
or my friend who wasn't seeing anyone um
model them and so this is my sister's
boyfriend and then that's my friend
and then my dad also got in on the fun
um but i wanted to show this because as
i mentioned we're making another virtual
issue
this fall and i found that making
when you're in a virtual world is like
something something that i found really
therapeutic
and i always felt like i was really
unproductive
when i was quarantining or isolating um
and so making things was a way to show
that like i was doing something with my
time and doing something that i enjoyed
um so if you're interested in joining
follow us on instagram at
infinite magazine and we'll be posting
about an info session that we'll be
hosting soon
um yeah and i guess going forward at mit
and getting
involved with the arts i definitely like
don't want to dismiss fashion as i did
before i got here because there's so
much research in fashion whether it's
sea sale doing robotic knitting or like
course three doing space suits
um yeah that's all i have
thank you great okay
um that was really nice thanks
so moving on sorry give me a second
ah my stuff is also acting up
yeah so moving on uh next we'll be going
to
chucho are you ready to present
yeah okay take it away
thank you uh hello everyone my name is
chucho campo
i'm an artist and an architect i
am second year now at ict
in the act program and
well um well i am here in cambridge
right now
and well
i think that the question is is quite
good what is it like to be an artist
inside of mit i think it's
it's it's a huge um
i think it's a huge privilege and it's
like it's a very fun
thing to be um because i think and maybe
i can
speak in regards of a ct
students as well it's like we as artists
tend to play with a lot of things and
are very curious about
a lot a lot of things that happen
especially inside the institution so
being here means you get to play with a
lot of
these things and you get to collaborate
as well with a lot of very
very interesting people um so i'll say
like that
first first of all that's kind of um
i think the main or the most attractive
thing is being surrounded by so many
people that are very much willing to
share ideas and
just collaborate and they're kind of
lending
also some of the tools and and the
things they are developing and
and it's back and forth which is super
interesting
especially like being an artist that
makes stuff and it's also inside in
between architecture media lab
ict it has a very interesting uh
i think space inside of mit which which
i think it's it's super fun
um another amazing
amazing thing it's i think the support
and the
the funding mit offers
especially arts at mit and all of the
grants that are available
are super precious for production
which makes things that which makes
prototyping and
making possible
and it's and that's not very common in
my experience so
being inside this place and also as
having the resources available makes it
like completely different experience and
also programs
such as like the residency program that
arts at mit has
that also relates to ect or misty that
also offers
certain things for artists as well and
yeah i think overall i don't have like a
specific project i think i've just
i like for the past year i have been
surrounded in this um
in this crazy environment but also felt
very much supported
not just financially but also
like by this really incredible array of
people
and facilitators and
i think that's it
okay great and um you were also
working on a collaborative project with
rt right
ah yes yes i think arctic can jump in uh
yeah if you want to talk together all
right just let it take over
one of these things especially i mean
obviously when you're inside this as i
was saying like if
you're inside you're being supported
you're you're building things
and then copied heat of course it
changed a lot of things
so i think most of us had to
shift media or medium and shift towards
a more digital platforms or
or or software
or other types of supports and that got
us
we realized we were working in very
similar ideas all together so we decided
to collaborate and
and make a project all of all of our
cohorts
together and maybe arty can talk
a little bit more about that so i don't
you're muted that will get muted right
now sorry yeah
so i'm going to quickly share screen and
talk over that
um so that it have an idea of what
exactly we were doing
um so i'm also sharing sharing
the link of the webpage in the chats so
you can also go through it
uh so yeah so this is um
something which as to said the five of
us we are five of us in our cohort and
we decided that
what happened we mean we had a very good
rapport with each other and then we
decided we suddenly were in different
places
without um the kind of support that we
give each other which is very important
for us with our own projects
and we decided that we would have to
find a way to work together regardless
of location
and we came upon this idea of um
putting together i mean came off the
exquisite corpse kind of
um general conceptual framework which is
to be able to put together different
kinds
of material and to construct something
out of
bits and pieces of multiple things i
mean whatever it is whatever whoever
brings to the table
so that was this so each of us sort of
um
modeled particular landscapes model
particular items
um maybe it was a room maybe it was a
walk
maybe it was an object and we converted
them to
um models with um
which which we could sort of push and
pull and
deconstruct and mix and put together and
we sort of created
uh fictional landscapes which each of us
were very embodied i mean
we were looking for an embodied kind of
relationship with these landscapes
so the link is in the website in the
chat and you can take a look at it it's
just
a couple of um worlds so to speak
and you can navigate through it and sort
of experience
sound um you can experience certain
kinds of uh texts maybe
uh things that we were writing on the
kind of movement we were interested in
so this is something which was uh it was
it i mean these are the
beginnings of i think a very long term
collaboration
between the five of us and all these
lines that you see here are also the
traces that people have left the kind of
movement people have created over time
um so this is that
and so i'm just going to stop sharing
right now
i think if if i can jump in
i think it's it's interesting to
[Music]
like to know like coming back to the
idea of mit and how it informs what we
do this
comes also from an uh from some of the
experience we had before
uh with an xr class on ar photogrammetry
and we're just kind of taking these
ideas which could be very technical
sometimes and we're just kind of
mixing them and making up making our own
type of exercises we kind of mix
matching
of of these things and we're creating
out our own methods of
of collaging you could say which is
which is kind of what the role of ict
is more or less now
yeah no definitely it was a very
interesting um
uh collaboration because and it also
i mean very uh it was
the beginning i think it's solidified
the beginnings of a very long term
collaboration we're only working
thinking of next projects thinking of
how cammit can help
fund our next projects because we now
are bursting with ideas and
that's something which i think we were
very
privileged to receive from gamet from
tsi which is transmedia
storytelling initiative which um um
we're all a part of now so
yeah i mean i didn't introduce myself
though i'm aarti sundar um
i'm in cambridge i've been here since
the start of covet i'd never left
i was threatening to leave but i never
left
and uh yeah i mean i
i largely work in with film in the last
year i've been working with film
so one of the things that was really
good for me
uh was to be able
to pull out of art in order to come back
to earth so i was able to take classes
across
mit and harvard i mean however i'm just
trying now but across mit say for
instance
in uh in dusk in which the media study
in
an sds in a labor department it was
something which
um was very crucial for my um
exploration of work and practice as an
artist and
this is something which i think i would
encourage if anyone would want to join
as an artist
in mit i would really encourage that
which is
to be able to um look across departments
look across campuses
and take things which you may not
think that um can help you but then
it sort of opens up a lot of um
ideas simply because you have experts in
multiple fields who are really willing
to drop everything and help you know
the moment you ask for a question i mean
it's something which
um is a great it's something which i've
been able to bank on which
i hope that if there's an art and who's
interested i mean i just think it's a
good space to be in and
i hope that works for everyone who comes
in as well
so yeah that's basically it
there's anything i missed out then you
can ask me
uh if you wanna you can talk more about
your next project you said you were
working on a new collaboration
oh yeah so we're looking at um okay we
just had a meeting today but we
should i say yeah why not
okay so we're looking at our publishing
now we're looking at what
kinds how we can convert this kind of uh
online first person interaction like a
almost like a gaming interaction into
a sort of a publication space
what would it mean what kind of images
are we talking about
uh because one of the things is online
engagement
but uh i think after three days of zoom
i think all of us have sort of
are yearning for a book yearning for
pages at some level
so looking at what kinds of printing
we're interested in what kinds of
images we would like to take offline
what kind of 2d
maybe pop-up maybe we don't know but
what kind
of um uh publishing platforms that
are maybe online or maybe it's a hybrid
not quite sure
but uh i think we're going to be jumping
into
uh making books uh whether it's um
doing it um like an artist book
or doing it as something which can be um
printed by um in in bulk i mean we're
not we're not quite sure yet but
we're looking at what would it mean to
publish
uh in a hybrid format what what does
that even mean do we have books online
we have books offline
so that's where our mind is going and
how do we build
on this fictional landscapes that we've
created
how do we convert that into something
which is uh potentially
offline as well analog as well so that's
where we
that's really cool well keep us posted
i'm sure everyone's looking forward to
it
okay and then next up we have danny and
element
and danny and my bad both on the same
screen with the really cool background
so
feel free to meet yourself and see that
hello
i'm alan and i'm danny um so
we both are recently graduated um
from mit and our majors were
computer science and comparative media
studies and we're currently both
in florida right now
um so looking back um
like in back in high school we were
always
um interested in various forms of arts
from like animation and
different fiber arts painting things
like that and
we were we were kind of worried that at
mit we wouldn't
be able to pursue those different um
forms of art but we were
throughout our course at mit we actually
were
um happily and unexpectedly
able to pursue all those different forms
of art that we were
hoping to um so we can
show some of the projects that we worked
on um so i'm gonna
share my screen um
so the um so first i'll talk about
i'll talk about the very first um art
project that we did at mit and then
danny's
going to talk about the the last one
that we did right before graduating
um so this is a project um we completed
in our freshman iep
um for this um kind of it came out of
it kind of popped up out of nowhere it
was called open mind open art
we saw flyers advertising it in the
student center and we thought it was
like a really cool opportunity to make
art during our freshman iep so we
decided to join that project
um the goal of it was to for ten student
artists to
create um their own projects
revolving around the theme of mental
health and wellness the project was
funded by
the mindhead heart initiative um
and what we really liked about this um
project and it was also like kind of a
community of people by the
by the end of the iep um it was really
collaborative and everything was
pretty um open-ended like we had this
general theme about
mental health and wellness but besides
that everyone could take their
projects in whichever direction they
wanted to so there were people who made
clay sculptures
people who made um paintings um someone
wrote poetry
um and what we decided to do was make um
this
fiber arts piece so we were really
interested in various forms of
fiber arts in high school like knitting
um sewing so
we wanted to kind of take that a step
further so what we basically did for
this piece is
sewed a bunch of little pieces of fabric
together specifically felt
um to make um to create this like series
of six
faces and the idea behind this was
um to kind of for the viewer to um
empathize with the
faces that we depicted here
um and we also kind of made this little
world
wordplay the the title of this piece is
um
stitched together so that kind of has
this double meaning because the
pieces literally stitched together out
of these pieces of fabric but
we also kind of wanted to evoke this
feeling um
that everyone kind of has either shared
struggles or shared experiences
um and can relate to each other even if
not initially evident
um so yeah that was this experience it
was um overall really fun and we were
really happy that we were able to
pursue this interest in fiber arts at
mit in our freshman year
yeah so then moving forward um
also in our freshman year actually
started by a few upperclassmen called
borderline which
um for those not familiar borderline is
um a student group on campus that's
responsible for the
murals um in the tunnels of mit's campus
um and the murals aren't just um just
flat images they also have an augmented
reality component to them so if you put
your phone over them
um you'll see an animation playing and
that
this club kind of started um it was in
our freshman spring as well and then
um ever since then um we both joined
the organizing team of the the club and
have kept it running ever since
along with a lot of other um really
great students who have contributed to
the club
um both on an organizational level and
on an actual art
creation and animation creation level um
so
the this group kind of um
started off as um just this project that
i think it was initially
just intended to be one semester long
but then it just
kept on growing and people just kept on
being interested in it and it
then became an official it's so the
this most recent project that we did
before graduating
um was a project that we did with um
with members of the borderline community
um
where some some of our members decided
to after getting sent home
we wanted to find a way to um still
create art together and
connect so what what they did was they
created this
website like a that was supposed to be a
virtual recreation of the tunnels where
students can submit
drawings of their quarantine rooms um
and the drawings can be really creative
so it doesn't necessarily have to be
like
a normal room but it could be
imaginative um so this is just a scroll
through of the website
um and then our particular contribution
to on this project was
that we added uh
[Music]
in the true borderline i want
the the screen is loaded okay there it
is but yeah
the video is loading but anyways um in
true borderline fashion we
didn't just want the the images to be um
just flat pictures we wanted to also add
an ar component to
it as well so um and i worked on
animating some of the cpw campus preview
weekend had just been cancelled
for um for the incoming freshmen um we
also wanted to
have the animations have a little
welcome message to the students that
were
unfortunately not able to visit campus
um so it was
it was um both a way to for students who
are currently here to connect with each
other
but
a way to kind of reach out to students
who are newly admitted
um virtual workshops for animation the
way that we typically would do in a
normal semester um and it was just
um something that initially i think when
we
first got had to get go off campus
we just thought that borderline wasn't
really going to be able to do much since
so much of what we do is is physically
like on campus our wall of murals is in
the tunnels
um and a lot of other projects that
we've done have had had
to be very much like at it on campus but
um we were able to find this this
creative way to
create art and connect with each other
despite all of that
and yeah and then i guess um
one of the other points that we wanted
to touch on is i guess what we're
working on now so since since quarantine
and we've been home in miami we we're
trying to find different ways to
continue
learning and expanding and growing
artistically so
recently something that we've been doing
is trying to learn
new skills like 3d modeling so we've
just been um
following there's a lot of free
resources online through like youtube
tutorials and things like that
um so that's kind of what we've been up
to now and
it's been a really cool way to learn new
things and
and kind of expand our art making
possibilities
awesome thanks so much yeah looking
forward to seeing that too
3d modeling is really cool i think i've
been trying to get into it but it's
really tough so
exciting to see how it goes okay and
then last but obviously not least
is uh joy joy are you ready to present
yeah can you hear me yeah okay okay
great so um a little bit about me i'm
joy i am
a junior in courses 6 14 and 18 and i
just declared my music minor
last week so that's happening um i'm
currently in california
and i'm here kind of repping the more
music and dance side of arts on campus
so i guess the most important part of my
campus like arts life i guess would be
that i'm the public relations director
as well as a traditional choreographer
for the asian dance team
on campus and i will touch upon that a
little bit more later
i'm also the ensemble director for mit
cello world
which is the cello ensemble and we just
started the organization last fall so
we're still relatively new
and it's it's meant to be like cello
world as in like hello world
and the cello ensemble like the
performing ensemble's name is called
cello plus plus
shortened to c plus plus um which i
think is cute
um i'm also an art scholar um run by
shea bro who is absolutely awesome um
and my freshman year i played for two
semesters in the mit symphony orchestra
and my sophomore year i played for a
semester in the
mit chamber music society and i played
piano and cello
mostly cello at school and i actually
wanted to kind of
bring up an exciting initiative that's
happening this fall so cello world is
collaborating with
um ribotomes which is mit's community
service music group
and we're starting a thing called the
muse project which
um i obviously like mit loves acronyms
so that stands for
music unites songs for equity
and it serves to kind of highlight the
work of black and
bipac just by hogan general composers
in the classical music scene so that's
going to be happening we're all going
to be like recording from home and audio
mixing and video editing
and um they will be released as like
kind of a series of videos just
to highlight the diversity that normally
doesn't get highlighted in the classical
music world
um so that's kind of all the stuff i'm
involved in on campus a lot of music and
dance things
and i just wanted to share my screen
really quick and kind of show you
some of the things that adt has been
doing asian dance team has been doing
um throughout quarantine because
obviously dance is kind of like a
what how do you do that during
quarantine kind of thing so
really quick this was pre-quarantined
adt
all right so this is pre-quarantined adt
these were some of our like very
professionally filmed and edited and put
together
covers um some of these we've submitted
to like
big cover competitions online and uh
most of the people you will see in these
videos came to mit as absolutely
like absolutely no background in dance
they were beginners
so it's always really gratifying as a
choreographer to see everyone grow
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
ah
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so that was pre-quarantined adt um
and i was actually in the second to last
video there i was in the back but
that video we filmed um nine takes
from before sunset to after sunset which
is how you saw the color of the sky
change which i thought was fun
um and this is quarantine adt
so in quarantine adt is still doing a
full set list
nothing is changing um all of our
rehearsals are held asynchronously now
and we also have just like on your own
time auditions where you just send us
videos of you dancing um and
to kind of pub for the auditions
we made this cute little um
kind of like a viral k-pop challenge of
the song that just dropped
and i think it's like number one on the
pop charts right now or something it's
kind of a big deal
so this is we filmed we had
choreographers film all the videos
separately and we just edited it
together and i think it's really cute
[Music]
[Music]
hey
yeah so that is what's going on in my
life and that is how i am
still trying to do arts in quarantine
well now that everybody has given their
most feel
it was great hearing from everybody um
we can open the floor to questions
we don't have too much time we got five
minutes but if anybody has anything
feel free to go ahead everyone and also
if any
if anybody in the panel has any
questions for anybody else feel free to
go ahead too it's nice to have some
crosstalk
but
if nobody directly has anything i think
some people talk directly about this but
if anybody else wants to
uh talk towards how corona has affected
their art
and like how they think they've like
changed or kind of addressed it within
their art
i don't know if anybody has any specific
answers but the thing i think a lot
about in terms of like
the art world and how it's not just kind
of affecting individuals which is
normally how like crises happen but
should be reflected across i think
everyone
[Music]
i think um in a way there's
in at least in ict what i'm seeing for
example this semester
is that a lot of classes are
[Music]
turning uh
their like their heads towards the
outside and the city
and outer experiences and i mean
obviously for practical reasons but also
like how do we continue
artistic research for example which is
what act does
how do we continue artistic research
and knowledge like how do we keep on
giving knowledge without the facilities
so this semester is super interesting if
you if you take a look at the subjects
most of them are either choreographing
uh
things in the city walking uh
thinking about like the outside not just
the city but like in general
um so i think that it changed i mean
it's
like super positive kind of adaptation
it changed very quickly
so i think that's one of really nice
uh things we could get at least
nice to hear yeah you gotta find the
silver alignments and everything
see that uh anyone else
yeah something i've noticed is that i've
just gotten
like more excited about making do with
what i have
and like seeing how i can get creative
with that um
like the pants i showed i guess are just
like viewing items that i have already
in a new light
um and turning them into something has
instead of like going to buy supplies
has like influenced my art and i
honestly think like made it more
interesting
and more fruitful
uh i think i saw someone in the audience
unmute themselves i'm not sure if you
had a question or if that was accidental
i do have a question actually i wonder
how much um
everyone's process has changed in the
context of maybe
the maybe your processing is private
anymore right like when you had
facilities
you could go into a space work on your
craft and decide
when to showcase what you're working on
whereas like now maybe we're forced in
environments
whether it's outdoors or in a house with
somebody else where
you have to go through the whole process
from conception to
you know refinement in a less private
setting and i wonder how that's impacted
if at all people's process and
experience
um i mean i can speak a little to that
um
one of the things which um we took a
decision
in our cohort in act was that we would
um isolate within ourselves so we
decided that we would make sure that we
saw each other and we found a way to
quarant
quarantine only with each other so that
we could continue i mean it was very
important for us to work together
so and what happened with corona was
that
it sort of um accelerated that process
of
trying to um because at some point
we only had each other and that really
made i mean the that also um
accelerated the process of collaboration
excel with the process of how do we work
together why are we working together
and what is the importance of going
offline and online being able to
um straddle both spaces with equal
forms of engagement equal level of
engagement
and the same intensity and complexity so
it's
which i i agree with you in the sense
that the
classes shifted i think the turning
point for the classes shifting was
when trump made that announcement and
then suddenly everyone's panicking but
that
once he resigned i mean that sort of
went off the table
um the the the idea of trying to go
offline did not go off the table which
was something very good
and um that i mean in many ways it's
it's uh worked for the better for a lot
of
us um of course there are
i mean i mean shop access i mean
equipment these things are always a
problem
but we have to negotiate that on a
one-to-one
basis but in terms of interaction
to be honest i think it brought us a lot
closer with each other
because at some point we realized that
we have to create a community
in a completely different space
altogether now
because different things are at stake
great
thanks so much um unfortunately this was
really great but i think that's all of
the time we have
i think stacy has a quick plug for
the gallery tour and then we can wrap up
yes so our last of arts on the radar
have been
for the evening is a gallery tour of
misalignments
and it's um two masters of architecture
students
um who did their exhibition in the
online wiesner student art gallery
and so they created a sense a series of
gallery rooms that each
kind of illuminated a different aspect
of their robotically fabricated ceramics
and so i will put the zoom room number
in the chat right now but i hope that
you guys can all join us in there
because i think it'll be a really
interesting talk and i hope to see you
all soon
in the chat thanks so much everyone oh
so good to see you all
have a nice night thank you
gracias thank you
[Music]
cutting across the archive from photo
montage to digital folklore
this advanced photography course is
designed for students who wish to
explore photography
images and archives as tools and
resources for artistic practices
the course focuses on the use of
archival images and photographic
practices while encouraging students to
explore analog
digital and
new technologies through lectures
readings film screenings
student-driven projects visiting artists
presentations and critic sessions
students experiment with a range of
artistic strategies while engaging in
cross-disciplinary research and working
on collaborative and individual
assignments across a diverse spectrum of
themes and historical context
students read and discuss theoretical
texts related to the use of archives and
artistic practices
advanced video and related media this
course introduces advanced strategies of
image and sound manipulation
both technical and conceptual we'll
cover everything from pre-production
planning
storyboards and scripting through the
refinement of digital editing techniques
visual effects such as chroma keying
post production as well as audio
and sonic components context is provided
by regular viewings of contemporary
video artworks
and other audio visual formats
video installation is a contemporary and
expanding art genre that intersects with
the world of architecture engineering
programming
new media and performance practices in
this intermediate to advanced course
students are encouraged to expand the
current themes and methods within their
art or research practices by
experimenting with various video
installation strategies
such as video mapping to 3d objects
site-specific architectural projects
multi-channel projection environments
mixing moving image content with live
performance
wearable sculptures live feeds physical
computing or
other elements of interest
you